importantly the dust up between the
governor of new york and the president
united states
as to who it gets to and how quickly
david spun
neil good morning to you from the white
house president trump at the white house
this morning continuing to embrace this
alternate reality that he either won the
race or the election was
rigged in his words posted numerous
times on twitter
continues to push that narrative twitter
has labeled many of those tweets as
misinformation but yesterday we saw the
president for the first time
in eight days making statements this is
the longest
we have not seen him for eight days he
came out in the rose garden
in front of supporters and medical
experts to speak about
operation warp speed something his
administration began
pushing last spring the good news neil
president trump says vaccines will be
available to the masses
by april just about anybody that wants
one the president said will be able to
get one
while talking about the vaccine though
as you mentioned he singled out
new york governor andrew cuomo listen
here
he doesn't trust the fact that it's this
white house this administration so
we won't be delivering it to new york
until we have authorization to do so and
that pains me to say that this is a very
successful
amazing vaccine at 90 percent and more
but
so the governor governor cuomo will have
to let us know when he's ready for it he
tries to bully
people he tries to bully governors he
uses government
as a retaliatory tool and as you know
wolf
new yorkers are not going to get bullied
and
i stand up for new yorkers and i'm
not going to let a bully push new
yorkers around
the trump administration continues to
block a transition to the incoming biden
team former white house chief of staff
and four-star marine general john kelly
out with a harsh statement that says the
president putting the country in danger
because he is not allowing
president-elect biden to receive
classified briefings
so biden can hit the ground running now
as far as lawsuits are concerned the
trump campaign
dropped a lawsuit in arizona as you know
fox news was the first to call that
several weeks ago
actually on election night for then vice
president by now
president-elect by meanwhile everything
goes on here in washington even if
president trump
does not consider will not concede as i
walked in today i could see the
reviewing stand for the inauguration
that's where biden and his family will
stand so things go on this happens every
four years regardless
but as of now president trump no plans
on conceding anytime soon still
neil you know david um the governor of
new york was critical of
the trump rollout plan for the vaccine
that's what he is standing behind
um and that the president went too far
to say all right well we won't make the
vaccine available until you
you have a better idea what you want to
do
are they close to any agreement on this
would the president really then say all
right
um you don't like my rollout plan i'll
roll it out to the other governors who
who want to have it
well you know it all depends on timing
leticia james she's the attorney general
for the state of new york
she says that if for some reason the
vaccine would be rolling out in what she
called the twilight
of the trump administration really the
next two months she said that they will
sue
new york will sue to make sure they get
the vaccine but ultimately when you
heard the timeline from president trump
yesterday he said for
many seniors hopefully in december as we
get into the winter months but for the
most part
it will be april when uh then at that
point president biden as we will be
calling him will be here at the white
house but
all indications are new york plans to
sue if president trump really does
try and hold back this vaccine
all right we'll watch it closely david
swan thank you very much we